through the burnt out suburbs of harkev
scorched by russian shelling heading
north towards what for months has been
the front line
but at a checkpoint ukrainian soldiers
confirm russian forces have pulled out
they moved from this region more than 10
kilometers from
this checkpoint more than 10 kilometers
but they they've pushed them back yes
they
go to russian border
we drove north to the place where
russian troops first tried to enter
harkev in the opening days of the war
sending a column of heavy armor down
this road
this is all that was left of it its
mission sunk in a ukrainian counter
attack
it's taken 79 days of intense fighting
but the ukrainians now say they are
confident they have won the battle for
harkeev there is still smoke on the
horizon and both sides are still
exchanging artillery fire but the
ukrainians now have pushed the russians
pretty much back to their borders and
now have a chance to cut off their
supply lines to the east
when the russians couldn't take arkeev
they tried to destroy it instead
shelling civilian areas people living in
these flats were forced to flee
going underground
as londoners did in the blitz they've
lived here on the platform and in trains
while the shelling went on above tetyana
and her eight-month-old son michaelo
have had to live in this cold dark
underworld since the start of the war
the first two or three weeks were
emotional and later you are just living
automatically but you have questions why
why we why ask for what why must my
child sit here underground why do all
these people have to be here
now they've been told the battle is one
on the surface but seem reluctant to
return home
and when they do this is what awaits
them a wasteland destroyed by russia's
now retreating army
dominic waghorn sky news hakeev